we begin with something that's not a
game a big change in the push to get
americans vaccinated with a focus on
those
who are so far unwilling to get the shot
president biden now says he wants 70
percent
that's right 70 of american adults to
have gotten at least one shot
by the fourth of july and the number is
currently at just over 56 percent so
there is plenty of work to be done our
lead national correspondent david begno
reports on the new measures to make it
easier to get the shot
in particular in rural america
this is your choice it's life and death
the plan has always been the same get as
many shots into as many arms as possible
but with so many people now hesitating
and demand way down
there is a new plan make getting the
vaccine
easier than ever by offering walk-in
appointments at local pharmacies
and expanding pop-up clinics welcome
back
this is your second dosage of modernism
just like this fema run site in queen
anne's county maryland
it's very important for people to have
these mobile units it's really
it's really a service for the community
ida jeffries who just got her second
dose
says she knows a few people who are
still on the fence about this as they
see their friends and their neighbors
doing things that they can no longer do
and they're no longer accepted in the
group i think perhaps that might be the
persuasion
the biden administration is also
planning to work with more local doctors
who they believe will be key to breaking
through that vaccine distrust in local
communities
dr stephen lakey is the chief medical
officer
at a hospital in fort collins colorado
in the northern part of the state
there are going to be a demographic that
are gonna be suspicious or or have not
heard the message
from either you know national sources or
from national news and i think having
that impact of having our local leaders
in those rural environments is going to
be critical
back in maryland vaccine administrator
cornell candidate
says some people have been able to
overcome their vaccine hesitancy
they're doing it for their loved ones
which you know that's
huge when you're thinking beyond
yourself
people like tricia and thomas stokes who
were expecting
a baby hopefully my baby is protected
that's what we're doing it for four kids
and
you know obviously people around us
and the next step vaccinating teenagers
as early as the end of this week
pfizer is expected to request emergency
approval to start giving the vaccine to
kids ages 12 to 15.
biden administration says as soon as
that happens they'll be ready to go and
as early as this fall
anthony pfizer's expected to request
approval to start giving the vaccine to
kids as young as
two all right david thank you